one thing that uh you did with fortnite
which I found really interesting was
that you have a skin in full yes how the
how did all that go about like was it
conversation they approached you like we
would want to put yeah no I think they
um they contacted every the first five
all together
and just said hey
we like you you want to be in the game
you're not going to say no so you say
Obviously yes
um and then you sort of just begin uh I
think for me it was like almost two
years yeah right on that first phone
call I think was August 2019.
um for a long time I didn't actually it
felt I didn't want a skin because which
sounds dumb but it's because I already
had a character uh the gingerbread man
oh right the merry Marauder that was
already so integral to my brand and
identity that I felt by just releasing a
skin for the sake of releasing skin it's
cool as it would have been it would feel
disingenuous because it would just be
black backstabbing the gingerbread man
well in some ways but kind of just like
I'm just forcing this out for the sake
of it I don't know like I already was so
attached to this thing yeah yeah but
then
um my girlfriend had the idea of making
it the old me like the young me before
who had the dream of like my fortnite
Skins are trading right what I did
beforehand yeah so it was just kind of
instead of trying to be some like
superhero looking thing yeah some crazy
easy outfit which they all look really
cool
um it was just more of like honoring the
kid that always dreamed of being where I
am now which is awesome
but that's why I was okay
yeah let's go the story behind it that's
my one one of my two tattoos is just my
Fortnight
what's your other tattoo oh [__] this I
I don't regret it but it's definitely a
lot it sounds like a lot oh
okay so when I I was a [__] broken
record I could not stop saying yeet like
you would have been I don't know I'm
assuming like the cold ones one comes
out before this yeah yeah but like Chad
all he does is say double it and give it
to the next one that's all he says he
always says to me so Mike same thing
broken record I couldn't stop saying if
it was already a dead meme so I made it
my meme the fact that was a dead meme I
just couldn't stop saying it yeah so and
then I was like it's a fun word to say
yeah but I was planning on getting
tattoos all up this arm so it wasn't
going to be quiet
yeah well I remember Joey went through a
phrase where he just would continually
dab even when the dabbing me oh yeah I
was getting that [__] alone yeah nothing
wrong with a good dab hit a bottle flip
I think one year it was like 2016 2017
way off to like the dab had already died
I was just like I'm gonna challenge
myself to see that if every photo I take
and I upload onto the internet is of me
dabbing oh God yeah and I did it for the
entire year if you look up any photo
from like 2016 2017 it's me Dad there
isn't a single normal photo I mean
that's holding a fidget spinner or
something yeah yeah yeah I should have a
double fidget spinner I hit a fidget
spinner with a sledgehammer once and it
slammed in my ankle and like like
fractured my ankle that's the one video
I made with the fidget spinner
yeah no it was like a metal one I was
like oh I reckon I could break this
Sledgehammer so I hit it and just
slammed in my me versus ten thousand
dollar fidget spinner it probably was
some green Jazz title
so you got the skin made and then it
came out and what was the reaction like
it was funny because like a lot of
people love the message behind it but
everyone who was an Australian had no
[__] clue what it was what was that I
didn't know what a train well they don't
want to trade it because it like what
was the skin name what was it just
called it's just called Las Vegas I'm
pretty sure I think it's just laser yeah
um what was the message behind it well
it was just pretty much just like well
his old self yeah it was my old self
because I I did a video and like I did
the lowest production value video out of
anyone who announced their skin it was
funny I did the thumbnail like 30
minutes before it went off I was sitting
in Disco with lucky like this looks
alright isn't it
it's only like one of the biggest
moments of your life he's throwing this
[__] together last minute I'm like Abby
right
um yeah so I kind of did a video on a
job site that uh my dad's working on
actually so it's kind of like it was a
throwback I went there I just talked
about the skin why I picked what I did
um so a lot of people really like that
but they're just like
like everyone else is all these glowy
characters yeah yeah hey look the skin
did well so I'm like people still you
know supported this that's we love that
but um yeah yeah everyone really
responded well to the message behind it
definitely and also another big thing
for fortnite creators that I don't think
I've seen any other game do is the
tattoo you have it's that in Roblox yeah
oh of course Roblox has a star code
which is also you can use code laser oh
my God but that doesn't do as well
because like
kids have to steal their parents credit
cards for that yeah you should not do
unless you are using Code I'm going to
explain what the Creator code is people
who might not know what it was one of
the most amazing brilliant things and I
will forever be grateful to epic games
for it because it basically allowed it
so you had another way to support people
making content so they made it so that
if when you're buying skins uh you could
enter a code and the person whose code
would get five percent of the purchase
right so it just gave us a lot there
were so many people who had like just
different forms of content map Builders
uh Instagram Pages things that didn't
necessarily generate lots of AD revenue
or something like that yeah yeah
for me early on when I was getting
really bad ad rates with fortnite yeah I
was still making decent money because
the views were so crazy but like it was
massive for me like yeah it was such a
massive thing for me
um it gave so much more security where
like you know ads were inconsistent
um right and that's just for me but like
percent of her skins especially for
getting to 10 million view video that's
yeah it was it was good it was good and
I think it just made it like so it was
viable for so many more creators to
actually make content full-time or yeah
you know be around the game full time
and obviously it was a brilliant
decision for them because of bred so
much Creator loyalty yeah yeah and then
yeah you see a lot of people do it now
um yeah yeah yeah well starting to at
least I think they're still doing it now
yeah no they still do it now although
the codes do expire every 14 days which
was brilliant from them because even I
forget to put my own code in when I buy
skins oh so you have to you have to
re-enter it every 14 days oh which is
fine because I guess the idea is they
want people to do different codes but I
thought you would have had to have done
it for every purchase anyway
the thing is is like a lot of people on
fortnite are on console and they'll they
want to type right so when I change my
code was originally laser beam and then
I changed it to laser and like usage of
my code went up like 50 60 just because
people are short and lazy yeah and I get
it I'm with them I'm with them that's
crazy that it's that big of a difference
though I just I can't remember the exact
number like but it was definitely like
significant increase oh wow [__] yeah we
talked to Lachlan a bit about the I
guess the economy of Roblox because I I
I know basically nothing the stock
exchange the stock exchange is [__]
mad yeah
and how like yeah they would like people
would I guess like make a [__]
Sweatshop or something except the kids
would like me maps
uh well I guess like what is that about
like I I did not get like the full
picture can you can you explain to me
what the economy of Roblox is Roblox is
yeah yeah
it's an interesting thing because I only
really make videos taking the piss out
of the game
like I'll I will just say I'll spend
like 10 grand and pay to win and just
like I almost say bully kids because
they can always leave the game so
they're kind of they're choosing they're
choosing they're choosing to get
destroyed oh yeah but yeah like all
these Roblox games not all of them but a
lot of them are pay to win right
um how so well okay so like I mean
one of my favorite ones is like there's
this game we can just like slap it's
like slap battles yeah you meant to
slowly grind the most people you slap
the more points you get you get a better
hand to slap people with it's like a
plane with Lego it's funny yeah but then
you can just go in and spend like 20
bucks and buy like a god hand and you're
unkillable and everyone who joins the
lobby you slap the [__] out of him and
he just you just knock them off the mat
and they can't do anything about it and
it's the funniest thing I'm like this is
ten dollars this is cheaper than a movie
and I'm sitting here at the time of my
life
so I guess like a lot of kids like just
love buying that [__] there's also you
can buy items it's like there's
thousands of games right um there's like
anyone can make a game anyone can upload
any game and then you can monetize it
however you want right right and I think
you get 30 so if someone spends 100 on
your game you get 30 right
um and yeah there's just a nasty cut
from them I feel like they provide the
servers the game I've talked to
developers about it because I thought
the same thing but the developer seemed
some of them at least seem quite happy
okay with it but you can create like
Cosmetics you can have so a lot of them
are like pet simulators and stuff where
you buy you buy and trade pets like it's
[__] Pokemon except they all just
look like squares and like bless those
guys they help me make a video so like
the game's fun and it's just addicting
and it's just like kids just love
collecting these pets and upgrading
their pets and having more powerful pets
and you know they spend money to get
those pets and you come along you're
like how could I best ruin this kid's
day oh absolutely so my big thing is
like I just like to spend a bunch of
money to get on high scores right so
like they'll be like these kids at a
grinder for months like you see their
play time 15 minutes 300 number one okay
and I'm like job's done it's a good
lesson to teach kids it's my most
popular video on my channel is the first
episode of that
it's just like a great video idea yeah
it was it was mad but so yeah like
basically just sell the Cosmetics
whereas for fortnite fortnite seller
skins in Roblox you just like people
make their skins right right you buy it
off the marketplace so even your
character that goes from game to game
someone's just made that skin so that's
why you get all the meme ones like
people just run around SpongeBob or like
you know any any character you can think
of any meme at any time right
um and that's just how and they just
take the cut off that it's all pretty
much all ugc like user generated content
Roblox is worth over I think well over a
billion dollars sure crazy that it's
worth I think it's it's the most
valuable game it's the most played game
I'm pretty sure it hits uh on update
nights for it which I don't know what
they are
um but it gets up to 10 million
concurrent players yeah it's it's not
like not like daily active like
concurrent yeah there is more people
probably playing right one of the
there's a game called blocks fruits
which has at any given time 300 000 to
600 000 current players playing a Roblox
game oh my God about being an anime
character I'm pretty I think it might be
based off like one piece but like a
rip-off block fruits yeah but it has
more players concurrently than all the
fortnite game modes yeah epic games his
biggest game has less concurrent players
than [__] blocks fruit and I'm like
that's a compliment to [__] boxers
because it's a great game but like what
the [__]
it works in a browser yeah it's on a
phone yeah man yeah that's like two big
things I'll just make it like easy you
know it's so Lego pieces with anime
swords
and there's more players in all of
because fortnite recently just showed it
so like they'll show their concurrent
players because they're trying to do a
similar thing where they like there's
all these fortnite Maps they want to do
a lot of ugc generated stuff
but and so now they show you how many
people are in Battle Royale right now
yeah
I gotta play blocks fruits
if probably every 10 year old in the
world is playing block suits that's
right and they are making tens of
millions of dollars a year how do they
get around copyright if it's like user
generated
the golden question yeah yeah I mean if
there's this much money
I feel like the big boys like say blocks
through it's just everything's a
different name everything looks slightly
different but maybe it's got a similar
energy but for people making like meme
skins I just
okay like they just like ban him if it's
like bad or something right right I
don't know but you'll see people running
around with some funny ass characters in
Roblox yeah because because I I guess
it's like it sounds like a similar thing
to like say VR chat or something where
all like the avatars yeah it's
definitely generated [__] great yeah
but except I don't think I think right
now it's mostly user generated and I
don't know if they're making a profit or
anything like that well there is a 600
000 people in VR chat yeah that's that's
the thing right that's the thing VR
Channel doesn't have block through man
it's crazy I don't know but it's I think
Roblox is also like the biggest game on
YouTube right now like firing away right
views right you just never necessarily
see it but it's yeah I guess because
it's if you're our age you definitely
don't yeah no it's it's not for me from
like a Content watching thing
necessarily yeah yeah yeah God I love
playing it it's so fun I recommend
everyone who has you know
like a little bit just